hey reject nation how you doing it's
Greg and I'm Kaila Lerman are you gonna
watch today from Kyle's channel fan
theory all I saw was the thumbnail for
this and you put this up on April Fool's
Day he kind of changed his whole channel
layout to look like ours too and I was
like alright I guess we'll do a reaction
of this gotta give props that boy he is
invented I don't know exactly what it
this is imagine as some spoof reaction
something we did know but all
after-effects I'll check it out not me
though I'm gonna look over here
hahahahaha trying to make you laugh Jean
that's some good comedy booth trying to
get a laugh pretty good person excited
about you got the chairs I know just
like a perfect green screen dude
[Applause]
[Music]
any great scurried all that therefore
[Laughter]
the spider reg levae it has a way Stefan
doesn't a very identical future see her
in this shirt
the only thing he's not doing is
grabbing his face a loss or arm scratch
[Music]
totally we should put the reaction
covering our face for this video yeah we
should green-screen files back
I have this like bro attitude I don't
know about I think he's trying to look
like me I think it's just Kyle as a
higher voice register driving I really
get any time you try to come down here
it's easy to sound bro it sounds like
Michael Keaton breaks like
[Music]
so we're divorced let's get you guys
what did change the longest video
[Music]
it's good sketch the faces are so
blocked
it's here look it got changed my stylist
he's got the wrist wear - oh no he's a
hundred percent good
I know if this jacket is Kyle has on
[Music]
we should have been a reaction T times
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
something I would say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how's complementing is a visual effect
[Music]
[Music]
game over
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
PACA dingy we're done we did it I don't
know how you when the hell did you get a
plate but when did we leave the chairs
unattended yeah maybe when we went to go
see Pacific Rim uprising he snuck a
photo baby because yeah that looks great
like it looks like they're actually here
the attention to details on this video
they were pretty top-notch they were
yeah they were they were at Kyle they
say imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery and I am thoroughly flattered
what a weird here for fools you know you
thought you came to the
it's a wig we should have uploaded yes a
blonde wig that's so funny again and
Stefan does just already look a lot like
you
Stefan's already it's always just like a
taller version of you yeah suspects in
some glasses I appreciate that he
painted his nails yeah you know like you
didn't grow out a stache though he
wasn't willing to commit that hardcore
hey man next time I expect soul patch
and a stache you know I wouldn't focus
the whole time is that I wonder how long
this took you to do Kyle and like your
impression of me yeah I sound like
Michael Keaton and and a bro yeah like
super bro II I'm excited about something
any comments on this video Kyle oh wow
stunning truly stunning and love it now
we gotta try to make fun of Kyle - I
know now we have to do it all I know is
his laugh when you do that repetitively
you remind me of just like one of those
Halloween standees that just laughs for
like 20 seconds and stops we're gonna
start watching like Buffy or something
yeah the old Buffy reaction the whole
season in fan theory style took the
longest video to do this - that's why
the only way to do you is to go hard
Clark or do one of your we watch
Whedon's yeah anyway Kyle this is an
honor I'm glad you put a lot of time and
effort to do this thank you again for
helping us with that sauce ketchup yeah
dude it wouldn't be what it is countless
other videos you've helped us would so
thank you and Stefan thanks for being a
good dude yes Stefan you got down three
of John's mannerisms buddy well want to
explain me in a video it really no Kyle
this is well done buddies I'm glad you
did it and then this is an honor this is
an honor to maybe this should be our
channel trailer yeah
yeah yeah new to the channel hey
subscribe to the real rejects you click
that notification bell we get notified
every time one of our videos is up and
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions to queue days and a lot
of goodies over there yeah yeah Michael
key
you